Oh today's episode is brought to you by
great block pizza and this is a pizzeria
that has oh just just pizza and things
that are gonna really make you feel good
inside of your mouth and body great
block pizza get that hitter
today's guest is making his second
appearance on this past weekend he is
the co-creator of the Chappelle show and
he has some specials on Comedy Central
ladies and gentlemen mr. Neal Brennan
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
but thanks man I just went oh you know
what happened I went to the pool the
other day dude you went to a hotel
called the hotel said hey can I go out
to the pool guy said yeah you can it was
like a gay guy and so I think out of the
gate it was like you know I don't sound
like that sound like like you know what
do you like with the phone I like come
on over that's really what it was like
so you know he was like yeah come on
over you know and uh and then what hotel
can you say yeah mr. C's hotel in
Beverly Hills and I called I went over
there was the only person at the pool
where's mr. C's hotel that's a guy's
house I don't know this is a hotel man I
went with my ex-girlfriend and we sat
out there and just caught some Sun and
here was the interesting thing though
there's no smog in the air so the Sun is
interesting it's direct
yeah it's getting people yeah and you
also have you have good skin you're tan
you tan yeah yeah I'm okay with that I
can I can handle Sun some people you
know handle yeah you seem like yeah I
can't you're a slave like if Sun sees
you it's like oh yeah we're bidding on
this guy get him yeah yeah like they're
that [ __ ] hey put him on the
boat let's go
yeah not crazy every time you leave your
house it's got to be like that I yeah
yeah yeah it's not that bad my dad you
see get again 10th might had 10 kids mmm
angry yeah you know violent all that all
the [ __ ] Irish have a fight the Sun come
he grew up the one of 13 kids born in
the depression like crazy he used to
know heartbeat I mean it it's he had
such bad skin that we would he we would
drop like we took it
we we took a vacation in California one
time and it's like seven of us in a
station wagon going to like Lompoc yeah
I just did whatever and my cousins are
in Lompoc you know that everybody saw
that coming
Neel parents definitely got positive
cousins in Long hug so my dad the first
day got such bad sunburn on his hands
that it bubbled up from the state bubble
yes through the window on this yeah and
I even remember I was like eight going
like you weigh how much were you driving
like how the [ __ ] did that happen bubble
up to the second day he wore black
gloves like a murderer driving with
black gloves on with like eight children
furious the whole time why do I see this
suddenly being a papillote hoon do you
see that Nick I suddenly see this be
right one of the anime trick I like it
yeah can you imagine the fatherhood you
have to have in you just the virility
you have to have first of all to have
ten kids then to sit there and hold on
to a steering wheel while your skin is
bubbling bubbling just to take your ten
kids to go see more fam Lompoc yeah to
get to go to solving yeah look at the
windmills and solving yeah it was a I
don't know what made it work I mean I
don't know what the I mean it's [ __ ]
crazy but the fact that he cuz then
later I went to the Caribbean oh my god
2005 if you can believe it and when you
somehow my feet my feet got sunburned oh
yeah the top of my feet and then I had
the bubbles oh and dude Ike you can't if
anyone's ever had blisters on the top of
their feet if I wouldn't rule it out for
you look like maybe oh you're done
you can't [ __ ] you can barely walk
like you don't have honor the the the
ecosystem of your foot is so delicate
yeah like a bubble on you you're almost
immobile it was [ __ ]
even know it was like from 10 minutes in
the ocean but it's usually not that bad
for me like I used to caddy but do you
have to think about it when you leave
home like I feel like you know if you
look at neighborhoods you have to think
like oh these people yeah look up for
this you know ants or something you know
hey yeah that's what you might do you
you meant ants first you know like if
you live like a you know like when I was
young you know the ants was always like
Oh are there ants out there yeah but do
you have to look do you have to think
about that like [ __ ] man
no if I'm going to the out there I'll
I'll think about if I like I live in
Venice then some time something goes
like let's take a walk my goodness yeah
and I'll be like we got to take a walk
all right
like if it's on the on the beach I'll be
like listen let's talk about routes
yeah I'm to like flip off to Libya we
got to turn around I see you in the
Caribbean going out to the beach at
night no I mean dude I it was wild
it was wild Turks and Caicos I got the
top of my feet got sunburned and I and I
like just putting a low on there Turks
and Caicos sound like a couple of Latino
hit men don't they the cutest Latinos
yeah you got that right little they're
at their mr. C's hotel this afternoon
yeah
did you drive over here in that Tesla
yeah man yes sure did did you get one
yet I didn't get one man but the new
ones I think are coming out with an
American flag hanging off the back we
were talking about this yesterday man
and it was literally the funniest thing
and I talked about in a while just the
fact that well Elon Musk tweeted some
stuff what did he write Nick he wrote
the the quarantine is quarantine is
stupid and then he's on some like free
let me open up yeah he wouldn't open his
business in Redmond I think it is
Alameda County Redmond he said they were
gonna have to arrest him he was just
gonna put his workers on the line yeah
he tweeted take the red pill yeah got a
lot of people it's he basically like all
the people who all the liberals who
bought a Tesla or now like what did I do
so [ __ ] funny cuz I love when anybody
gets [ __ ] over I don't get livid
[ __ ] hilarious it's kind of like when
hulk hogan started wearing that black
stuff everyone he started wearing the
black mustache right
yeah i remember it and you're like what
is going on yes oh yeah that's so
bizarre yeah but you tweeted something
too about it didn't you it was so funny
man did you tweet something about it no
I mean I've tweeted like I'm on the side
of like scientists and stuff yeah that's
funny that's a lot on the right and all
the holy lawns like I got a lecture I
believe in electric the electric future
brother yeah America gasoline 'less
again baby yeah it's all canceled
culture he's just been going in yeah
he's a basically just on some maggot
it's correct he's some piece dong zhuo's
podcast why he's like what the [ __ ] who
is this guy liberals are gonna have to
get now they're all stuck with the cars
and I don't think ours is you can't
lease them right yeah i you can i least
mine I didn't think you could but you
can't I thought you had done no I am I
gonna get rid of this and just come and
take it stuck with this electric
American flag right um what do you been
doing man
what have I been doing um not much man
how often you hang out with your
ex-girlfriend we ain't got a pretty good
bit we turned it in like just really we
turned into like really good friends you
know she's she's pretty much like my
best friend do you think like well maybe
for Nick maybe Nick shocked to hear that
but uh hell of a way to find out we talk
every three days I'd hate to meet his
enemies yeah we just well during
quarantine it's like you kind of I think
in the beginning like we hadn't been
talking for a while and then Gus
everybody got spooked you know yeah so I
was I know that she was kind of scared
and they got was scared so I was like
you know you just wanted to be around
people that you cared about if you could
be around anybody
were you scared cuz when
we talked at the beginning you were like
[ __ ] better be real called me like
hey what is this you're like is this
real you know I didn't know and I didn't
know if maybe you knew something I
didn't know like you know probably my
mem know rich people like do you know it
yes Blake is like Griffin yeah like is
he how's he dealing with it ya know
they're they're all they're all good all
the rich people are abiding by it yeah I
mean oh it's super comfortable I mean I
think this thing's been pretty
comfortable it's a ver that's a funny
way to go it's like this is a pretty
comfortable national sacrifice yeah if
you have money if you have some money
right if you've just got off the road
right a podcast if you have either a
savings or a thing you can do without it
right I agree it's a it's kind of a
vacation if ya if you're in the second
month of using the 1200 or stimulus
check and you are like what the heck is
gonna happen next
yes and you're waiting on pins and
needles for the government to send
another check that's that's that's not
that's a different person's life yes
that is that is truly [ __ ] gotta be
horrifying and scary [ __ ] like our Tower
and I wonder how then like at that point
do you like do you feel like you would
batten down with like your wife and
family or do you think you'd be like I
got to get away from them you know like
they're the ones bringing me down yeah
well they they people were all saying
that domestic violence is gonna go up it
but the stats I saw it didn't go up that
much went up like 5% I haven't seen
anything and there's always people
beating chicks in the park bar over by
where I live or by at Park Park Park
there's a card Westwood is a lot of
homeless people out there people they're
just you know not not home or just
aren't going home basically and they bar
serious fights it do you really oh yeah
you know what's funny about fights at
night is you know like you ever be like
line a bit it's like 1:45 in the morning
and you'll hear like and you're like
well I hope that works out yeah like I'm
not getting involved into that I wish
him the best but I'm not calling I'm not
leaving bed and I'm not investigating in
the slightest yeah total opposite of
what I'm doing right you made your
choices here is it worse sometimes I'll
be like will you keep it look I don't
know what y'all are going through yeah I
don't that is the funny thing we're just
like oh yeah good luck do you think
sometimes I feel like if this is like
our Vietnam this is like the softest
thing it's nothing but it's nothing for
us cuz just like Vietnam would have been
nothing right we're not in dry like
frontlines yeah like we would have been
you would have been I mean if we were
eight if we were 18 we'd probably be
gotten drafted
you probably got drafted for me really
yeah cuz I think they did like I would
have been able to call or whatever you
had something like what keeper somebody
yeah yeah I would like my foot hurt or
something and they believed it look at
the sunburn I can't man you got y'all
better have some SPF yeah I'll go but
like how much how much sunscreen yeah
the I feel like southern people had to
go I'm sure I'm wrong about that but I
well I think you they were probably more
adamant about it it's like they'd be
like you don't have any arms and legs I
can do it sir yeah or yeah but I also
feel like like I in to my mind
Vietnam was all like black Latino and
seven whites yeah in my head like that I
don't even know that's true I'm sure
what did you get into Iowa Pennsylvania
yes hon yeah that's where a lot of your
white service people come from my book
and then yeah I guess the South is well
what is this just casualties during
Vietnam but it doesn't split it up by it
has all one side together so US has
lumped it with people but there were 1.1
million deaths on that side but there
was also a draft right so that's what
I'm saying and a draft I think they
favored I'm sure like I went to college
you went to college yeah where'd you go
to college oh yeah I did
LSU I'm gonna tell us you yeah I went to
a couple different spots but I
definitely would tell us you trying to
find your groove what yeah I just wanted
to be on the move man I just seemed so
weird to be like we're
I'm in one place is it I feel like this
is it
is it safe to describe your 20s as itchy
oh yeah oh yeah man I mean like what are
we here man everybody somebody's over
there I always had to go there was
always something yeah where else yes
Oh something's bugging out trying cuz I
don't know do you talk about your 20s
much on here
I mean honestly dude it's hard for me to
remember some of it you know because of
drugs alcohol mm-hmm I think just
because a time like it's just hard to
like yeah like our lives are so
interesting now like I mean I remember
in my 20s you know like I'd done reality
television and then I moved and then I
traveled around a bunch to different
schools and then I went on semester at
sea it was like a school on a cruise
ship and so with that forward TV no that
was just like he's a student got it so
it just after the reality thing yeah a
couple years after I just got a job in
the bookstore on this cruise ship and we
went everywhere we went to Vietnam
actually and did you like being on the
boat yeah it was pretty fun do you start
to become like Lord of the Flies on it's
called semester at sea you start to
become like in the beginning everybody's
kind of chilling you're like okay this
is what's up by the end by the end of
three months like you would be literally
sitting in class in a mayo bikini like
everybody like it was like everybody's
sunt and everybody like you'd be trading
like shoe polish for a little bit of
liquor at night like it was just oh yeah
it's the probably not a bar right but
they had a bar but you if you want your
own liquor you can only have two wines
you could each get you could get two
wines so you could like you were a lot
two glasses of wine yeah did they and it
was drinking age was 21 drinking age I'm
not sure it must have been 18 I think
cuz you're out in the ocean because once
you get out in international waters it's
oh right maybe there is no drinking age
yeah I mean you do was yeah it was
really bizarre it was bizarre being on
there were you drink a lot oh yeah you
could drink and everything nobody was
doing drugs or anything I didn't I
wasn't even doing drugs at that point in
my life I didn't even drink that much
but yeah every night people will go
drink play games and were you one of the
better-looking people
I've always been about 1/8 if I have Sun
on me I definitely look better because
if you get a tan it kind of makes your
nose look a little smaller and snug
you're very insecure about your nose you
have a badonkadonk yeah I got that
[ __ ] the face down I got that junk in
the front trunk
you know Brennan said I should wear a
thong on my nose sometimes I do hope one
day my nose is in a little busi video
that's what I'm I uh but it was fun man
it was funny you we went to all these
countries we went in South Fidel Castro
speak in Cuba really yeah and was it
remarkable mmm a lot of mean if you knew
Spanish had definitely helped but it was
like a four-hour speech about how the
stuff that he did in Cuba like the
things he implemented like the positives
of it yeah so it was kind of uh what
would you call that propaganda
propaganda yeah but was he a good
speaker or was it very good yes tall he
kind of had it was kind of like a little
bit of like a I don't want to say like
I'm Mexican Phil Jackson kind of but he
kind of had that you said it and it's
right yeah he kind of had that I Lindy
Phil Jackson kind of yeah I've you know
the suit and then some kid ran down
there and wanted to get his passport
signed by him and everybody who got all
excited and he was shot that was fun man
yeah that's cuz I feel like you I was I
was at CVS yesterday and I thought about
you for some reason Thanks there was a
lot of they were just at what point were
you like a flip-flop person yeah yeah
alright cuz they were just flip-flopping
while I was like I feel like Theo was
probably this at some point maybe when
you're on the real world or the heard
those shows were you kind of that kind
of guy I don't remember really I mean I
definitely remember in my twenties
minutes so it's so crazy a lot of that
part of my life just just those years
just kind of blur OTT I remember going
to like you know I went to different
colleges I went to Loyola you know it
was just yeah and your 20s I was more
like you know muscular kind of big hair
kind of guy just you know happy to be
alive
you know you're like a lot of erection
pills back then is that true oh yeah
yeah I had a lot of like social life
sexual anxiety in my 20s and it was hard
to get him now you can get him anywhere
he'll we have some you know you know a
buddy of mine smelled NICs breath and
catch a boner now I mean you know I'm
just saying it like every everything in
here is probably sponsor balance what do
you mind reminded me of a story
yesterday where he he had he was in a
relationship he had Edie with the girl
cuz like he couldn't get over her ex and
then she got upset because of it like
she's like you don't think I'm
good-looking and so he went to an
erection doctor first of all took the
bus to the to the erection doctor which
you don't just right there you've
already lost
well I can a bus I'll keep my dick down
for us yeah oh the erection doctor gives
him basically I think it sounds like a
cialis or something this is like 20
years ago hmm
and he goes you're gonna get an erection
and at a certain point like if it if it
doesn't go if it if you don't get an
erection within the next two hours
something's wrong and if you do you know
it'll be fine and but if it doesn't go
away you got to come back okay so my
buddy takes the pill oh yeah you gotta
take a night walk out the door I just
boned you [ __ ] bareback right then so
look like I took it he goes to see the
Mel Gibson movie payback and just gets a
rod just like a rod where he's like wow
this is really it starts getting
uncomfortable and he's like [ __ ] he goes
to the bathroom yeah it's hard it's a
hard you get real hard he goes to the
bathroom and it's like all purple huh he
goes he's like I can't wait so he
literally like kind of shuffles back
just kind of with an open boner through
his pants yeah and the doctor he said
the doctor looked at it you know how the
doctors aren't supposed to react he
could tell the doctor kind of
like oh and then he's like alright we're
gonna have to take it down doesn't say
what that means and yeah it's not like
it's a flag in a few okay good all right
is it that simple we're gonna suck how
are the trumpet yeah because we get a
blanket over there's nothing you can do
yeah sound like a parrot it's like a
[ __ ] tea cosy so uh so he he he goes
the doctor literally says my buddy he
takes out like a huge vote like a huge
syringe and he says my buddy you're
gonna want to grab the bottom of the
table which is like goddamn he sticks it
in his dick the blood my buddy said
spray into the syringe and took it and
then like just he just drained the blood
out of his out of his dick and what did
I do with the blood I don't know how I
hate to tell me oh I draw away you want
about what that goes to your penis yeah
that's good blood
that's extra valuable blood that's the
good stuff
but my buddy said 20 years later he
still has a scar on his dick which is
[ __ ] insane so that's that's my boner
pill story dude that boner pill story is
so good it's not even yourself I know
it's not even mine and he reminded me of
it yesterday
this same buddy has one of my favorite
stories is you know the hill on La
Cienega by sunset yeah when you're yep
and and my buddy had a a I don't even
yeah I guess he had a stick shift but he
went on he was on that like 8:45
couldn't get up to the point where he
just was flipping out so bad that he
cause like horrible traffic and then he
finally just had to like pull over into
one of those driveway you know like back
up into one of those driveways it isn't
he just couldn't figure out how
Volkswagen Rabbit do you know I don't
know but like the tires are skidding and
people were just going around them that
[ __ ] makes me laugh so he just had to
abandon his car after a while this is
like I can't I can't do it now it's not
the time you those rabbits of hillary
router
yeah they were not rabbit halfway up a
hill man yeah now you now they got it so
it'll stick but back then my mom used to
have one I'm least I always have to give
up on a hill you know yeah like he'd be
going like oh yeah there it is right
there look at that back yeah that was
the one
yeah and a lot of the gas was in the
trunk to the way I had to Adam built so
it was like that was one of the problems
a lot of the gas would just even way you
back even more it was a it was a real
test beautiful it was a test of what a
hand i coordinate like figuring out
you're going backward and yeah but he
just didn't any excuse me oh yeah this
house was scared and like getting and
it's you know rush hour in the morning
and finally just quit this is not for me
I have I have a segment that I want to
play with vo no and we talked about it
before I don't know if you're rolling
but that I look at Co the the wonder of
Pheo is that I don't know what you're
gonna say from minute to minute okay I
don't know when you're on with age I
don't know what you're gonna say you're
gonna it so I so the my point is I don't
know what you know hmm I have no idea
what you know okay good as I told you
you doin your act you look like a guy
who who has matches right yep I believe
that you look like if I could be
anywhere in the world if you text me and
said I'm outside I would believe it okay
alright I come and get like just yep
that Theo is outside that makes any
[ __ ] anywhere in the world I gotta go
to get Theo what we're at the United
Nations
he's outside he said he's outside okay I
believe that I don't know what so the
question is I don't know what you know
and I feel like you know I know you know
more than I think you know okay but I
don't know what the
breath of the knowledge is okay so we're
gonna play a game show called what does
Theo know I want you to play along at
home maybe you'll throw some music
underneath this some game show music
playing at home
what does Theo know and I just tell you
things all right no I'm gonna ask you
questions and what and then people will
guess whether you know it or not all
right okay and I'm gonna guest you yeah
you will you will tell us I'll tell you
if I think you know your way in he knows
you know what he knows I think I know
but I don't know what you know yeah no
one knows what Theo know hey let's do it
name five members of the 1985 Chicago
Bears I believe you know this you almost
don't cuz of your age but I believe you
can muscle it out all right I'm gonna go
with you boy um Shaun Gayle who Murder
House white [ __ ] no then if you know
Shaun Gayle but I know that because I'm
a Dateline fanatic outside of that I'm
going with your boy oh I will go with
this ah the quarterback that legend Jim
McMahon okay who I met at a golf term
out in Palm Springs and he had this
little kind of thick Jewish woman is his
girlfriend and she said he he goes this
lady will always eat my butt that's what
he told me was his I thought the that's
the sort of thing I expected you to know
and bro I watched him drink 18 beers man
at this yeah that guys have what he's
like yeah and he would stand up when he
would say that about the lady any we
kind of he had pants on because I kind
of pulled his book apart which was crazy
yeah and uh and I think I got high with
them actually but um but anyway so Shaun
Gayle I showing it I don't know if was
on that team they he might have been
after that team but I'll give you Shaun
Gayle and all the gym ago your boy
Richard dent right Richard dent yeah if
you know Richard dent and you're gonna
I'm gonna go with sweetness Walter pay
up we're up to four and I'm gonna go
with a course who else is it it's that
guy frigerator Perry
yeah keep got who else do you know Shaun
Gayle the killer right there
yes he was on the team yeah he was
I believe he returned kickoffs I believe
he returned his wife to heaven - yeah
Rhoni Reuter Willie Gault returned for
the Willie gold really don't ya
goddamn dude blanket Wiest have much
more kind of old-school names I feel
like yeah they had like it was before
the apostrophes and the Kwan's and yeah
Willie go you know they have like
southern they had like sharecroppers
names yeah they had definitely like
holdover like second third hand kind of
yet named like that like I remember like
uh you meet a guy named lilac or
something like that and you'd be like
that is a cur you know Lal la la si yeah
like the like the flower yes or Toby or
Toby uh all right Toby's a little too
Toby's Allegra no me I can't get I can't
and you know I can't endorse that have
you seen that roots movie yeah me my
grandma watch that Chris you know what's
interesting every Christmas you want to
know just one time but we watched a good
four hours well first of all to get the
feeling to get the Christmas spirit with
my grandma gets wrapped into something
she it was anybody who watches it more
than one four hours jesus what about a J
Simpson is in it Oh Jay Simpson is
enroute yeah that's I forgot about that
there's a lot of legends in that movie
um who else Sterling Sharpe maybe no
other than making a new one they did
make it it came out it just wasn't that
popular oh wow
with it you know what was interesting I
read an article on Michael Jordan
yesterday there was a new one on ESPN
where they said he used to be super
disruptive in class after he saw roots
really which was like kind of mine
wanted me because he just seems so
apolitical yeah but he saw roots in 79
or 7n was like started [ __ ] with
people I'm assuming white people which
is really surprising there's a good it's
a long article and dude I remember
seeing it I got it through Netflix sent
it to me
and this is when you had to get each
week and I was like holy [ __ ] the old
one yeah I was like what happened to
these people like they kept saying like
I get a weight ya hit a wait for you in
the mail and I look back and you felt so
bad you would just make weight off may
Allah help you like just wait like man
I'm just how are you to apologize all
about yeah I'm walking to the mailbox
again yeah you're learning a lot Ed
Asner isn't it yeah I love Lou Gossett
jr. yeah plays uh I believe Fiddler's
name he was good yeah it was yeah Lou
Gossett you know George you played
Chicken George did he pass away I don't
know what did who pass away what about
this 6-nothing Gossett junior Louis
Gossett jr. do you think we'll ever get
to a place where six nine will be in it
we'll be in roots what the rapper six
nine I don't Oh Takashi like--yeah do
you think oh like Yale will do another
roots and a remake and he's I don't
think he could I don't think he could
play a slave oh he's also not black I
love Puerto Rican but but you know what
I'm saying well I know a horse diversity
and said with with everybody on being
allowed to play ah yes yes and he yes he
would qualify as a lesbian and now okay
going name can Theo von name for films
directed by Spike Lee I think you can I
don't think I can but I'm gonna do it
I'm gonna start think about your answer
before he begins first of all I don't
like Spike Lee okay so that's why I
picked him he's a he's a he's a
political [ __ ] I don't care about the
direct I mean I yeah so the movies or
whatever I mean I liked definitely white
men can't jump and poetic justice he was
not involved in either of them are you
serious he got aim he wasn't even close
to them are you thinking he got game
with Denzel that was likely I was seeing
my white men can't jump why I can't jump
you're thinking of he got game you're
they dove
yaaaaah I just think what's the times
overrated that's what I mean I shouldn't
sound like am i shouldn't say he looks
like [ __ ] I just you know he looks like
somebody that [ __ ] manager Coleco uh
like one of those places at the Dave &
Buster's we go cash in the tickets he
looks like the dude that managed that
like 40 years and then I just don't
think he made that much good stuff what
did he make good so that's you can't you
that's not answer no interest okay
all right that's the I figure there
might be a limit there but I'm surprised
but I'm still surprised
oh well Mac at Mac I met Malcolm Malcolm
X Malcolm a fever
I haven't very much the original one
yeah that's yeah that's well yeah from
like 91
oh yeah that's spike Wow yeah
black clansmen you see that no I didn't
see jungle fever she's gonna have it he
started taking else pretty regular I
just think it he's overrated I'm sure
he's probably a neat guy yeah 25th hour
people like that movie I didn't like
iMovie bamboozled he got game he got
game you know what's great about he got
game just watching Ray Allen shoot Willy
so it's Ray Allen plays like a college
basketball phenom yeah and there's
scenes where him and Denzel are arguing
and Ray Allen's shooting jumpers and he
makes like nine in a row from three at
one point but it's in this it's in a
scene and there's no edits right and
it's [ __ ] you never see someone shoot
like that like it's [ __ ] it's crazy
cuz you just see a guy just make where
you like are you you know you ever watch
like Steph Stephanie videos where he's
just like you know like this is weird
yeah he's a lot of electronics yeah like
I feel like he might be a wish that
haunted by a video game yes I got a
question for you how long do you think
Takashi six nine will live I think it's
under a year really I really do I don't
I think he I just think someone's gonna
kill him like for all the what he did
yeah I don't see how you survive that
and I also don't see how he
bodyguards like I don't I don't how
desperate must have bodyguard be cuz
your he is also gonna die but bodyguard
that's your job I mean you don't I don't
think you have a bunch of plans if
you're a bodyguard you know what I don't
you you don't have like a five-year plan
you don't have like I want to be here
then I want to be a different kind of
body like yeah be big and walk and get
hit on stuff yeah stand in front of [ __ ]
get hit by car take arrows yeah do you
but with that said with that will you be
a little disappointed when he dies I
think he I'll say this I find him to be
a hilarious cartoon brat yeah in the
abstract you want to talk about a living
troll yeah I mean they living a live
he's like he's like if you remember that
Twilight Zone where there's a thing on
the wing there's like a monster on the
wing in the plane uh-huh it's that's
what Takashi looks like he just looks
like like a little goblin goblin he's a
[ __ ] legend that thing dude I mean I
think he I think I agree I don't think
he's gonna live that long okay is that
we're talking about yeah this looks like
some Spike Lee will be 83 version that
one's good that guy he's more of like a
snow dude but here's the thing though
his music is good
oh yeah that's a thing as I've never
listened to music I will say I listen to
xx Nixon tascioni after he died and I
was surprised by how good it was yeah I
was like oh this is like there you go
that's more what I was thinking but he
trolls oh yeah well he's gonna work it's
gonna be a unique world that he lives in
because he's always gonna have to be in
hiding unless does he have to go back to
jail do you know Nick if he has to go
back to jail after the virus I don't
know where it's at I don't think he's
out cuz of the virus I think he's out
because of the I think he's out because
uh
because he just did he turned state's
witness but here's the thing did they
even bust anybody he snitched on uh I
think they did they must have I don't
think they I don't think they would
bargain I don't think you would get a
plea deal if you didn't have good
information because that's what my
guilty pleasure is going and watching
his stuff sometimes and seeing what he's
up to
you know I watched the video he's yeah
he's a he's a he's a tree he's a living
troll yeah but he recently tried to out
billboard he was saying that Justin
Bieber and Ariana Grande paid to get
number one on the Billboard yeah he was
saying that like at the last minute
people would buy you know listens to
their songs or something so right yeah
but I mean I think that kind of stuff
has always been like those charts can be
manipulated I feel like yeah well what's
funny is like the song is called I'm
back and they mad yeah well it's like
yeah you of course they're mad you
[ __ ] snitched on a gang he did lie or
he snitched or whatever but I can't
believe there's so much is there a lot
of like is there a real code of conduct
between some of these [ __ ] really I
think the only yeah code at black don't
seem like he has a real code of conduct
you know yeah I think the thing is
you're not the one thing you're not
supposed to do is you just can't snitch
if you're all doing a crime you can't
you give me a clip right that's the only
I think that's the but none of them yeah
that's a good rule yeah like none of
them had like you to your point I don't
think they don't have a code but it's
they start doing it because they're
desperate and then it's like well they
made that decision they did crime
because they're desperate they're gonna
turn cuz they're just gonna what's the
desk and if you're in a desperate
situation and he's gonna take the he's
just gonna continue to take the I bet he
dies of an overdose
that would be Maury yeah I don't I'm
sure
his existence is a form of misery as
like angry and [ __ ] ha it's it's got
to be scary ish like your body can't
take that kind of
dress yeah I agree the constant like Oh
dim them them like them them them and
you really do have people out to kill
you yeah to kill you someone could
openly say I want to kill you and
everyone be like even the cops be like
but is he now under with witness
protection is he under or police
watching him like are they protecting
him as well I don't that I don't know I
don't know I don't think the cops are
gonna protect him but I don't I think
raising room with shame right manatees
I'll tell you what we do here's a
question we don't know this we
definitely don't know all right
what is Takashi's plea agreement all
right this one I think you will get all
right name three people who have served
as governor of California Oh Gavin
Newsom mm-hmm
sunny Sun I know this I can't believe
you're about to say here you're gonna
say really I can't believe that you I
could not even remember this one I don't
know if I remember but let me thank Reed
I think his name was sunshine brown mmm
Sun sherry
yes Jerry sunshine sometime was like his
nickname yes sunshine Jerry Jerry Jerry
Brown uh-huh Wow and uh oh
VRR gasa and Antonin via Ragosa no I
don't think it was governor wasn't oh oh
he's the mayor yeah yeah yeah I thought
those were the ones I thought you would
get I thought you might get Pete Wilson
they wrote there was a second governor
of he's really old but his name was
Sonny James rorimer all be honest did
you mean Sonny general no looks like he
definitely has or he would get sunburned
he does he would have to wear leather
driving gloves if he drove my family
around look at that mustache what a
mustache that's a goddamn broom what do
you uh are you like what are you okay
with
right now like what are you okay with
far as like socially right now do you
feel like um I don't you go on a date
would you take a date somewhere I don't
think I would I don't think I would uh
because I don't I mean would I have a
date over I don't think I would do that
either in that I don't want someone I
don't know at my house right but is that
just a general rule of thumb no I would
well no the problem was that was like
mice I mean I would just go like let's
just go to my house and like a nice
place
yeah it's nice but it's not like mmm
it's nice but it's meaning I'd rather do
that then like let's go to the [ __ ]
bumper car or whatever people do on date
right miniature got like I just wasn't I
don't really drink so that really
reduces what you can do on dates as you
know yes you'd rather take just some
more low-key approach really let's just
order some food and talk and talk and
watch Netflix and talk [ __ ] and which if
you're gonna make a move on a chick you
kind of do the couch kind of move is it
that so yeah I have a couch and yeah but
it's like you kind of scoot closer on
the couch you I feel like most of my
first kisses in the recent life have
been in my car it's a Tesla so say no
more serious serious it's proving the
opposite of what you want it to signal
wait till one date is press a button in
the Patriot plays bald eagle so it's
been like but on the couch yeah it's you
I'm really is it like the first kiss on
the couch usually it's in the car cuz we
go somewhere or whatever oh yeah yeah
and then I think okay goodbye
and that's what it what are you like
yeah this is always a moment I feel like
if like cuz he like I feel like here's
how you know I feel like if a girl
doesn't want to kiss you she gets out of
your car real fast so that's the vibe I
kind of take is like okay there's an
opportunity to kiss maybe kiss here you
know I think if there's any delay they
the here's that one of the if there's a
delay in like okay so then do something
now if she double check sometimes a
little double check their bag go do I
have everything
yeah do I have my own keys that can
sometimes be a faint that can be like a
fake out that like kiss or that's not it
that's not a green light yeah if there's
just a delay like a beat of like huh
that's the time a thing that I do
sometimes do is I will say maybe a half
hour before I'll be like you know I'm
gonna kiss you just so you know oh
at the end of the day just FYI I like
that yeah Cupid's arrows coming no Cupid
arrow I got him in my quill I like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah little just say FYI
oh I like that's a good idea cuz it's
it's like flirty but it's kind of like
dirty it's you're asking you're
basically asking for consent psyche
reversed and you're asserting you're
being assertive which women like yeah
they like like I wanna guys like
assertive and like so you just go I'm
gay and then if she goes no you're not
then you okay yeah you're like you're
damn right I'm not I don't even like it
yeah okay I can hate mouth now here's a
crazy thing do you ever notice like my
whole life I've been like this like I've
been like so if you are like I just
don't know what I'm talking about and
then my brain kind of shuts down and I
can't even hear what I'm saying anymore
and then I'll just go in like there is
that thing no it's like when there a
bomb goes off in a movie whereas like
there's a bit like
that's what it's a bit like before
you're going to move in Oh Chris where
there's a bit of like it's a netherworld
underwater it's not normal life it's a
little heightened and there's a little
like fear it's like a move it's like
we're taking this to the next I'm always
like yeah I love going to different
places there's a something like boys
last your last line before you make out
it always always like a bummer like no
you're right we should yeah
oh really your parents are seconds are
great they have overinflated the Cova
death ray yeah that is a funny I
remember the first time I kissed a girl
it was like I was like in sixth grade
fifth or sixth grade yeah and it was
like sponsored by another couple who
were hooking us up me and this girl
he's like a church group no well it was
Catholic school it is man so they were
like we're all going let's go to the
park make out with Margaret was her name
this is back in the 1800s Little Women
yeah it was Little Women
it was Little House on the Prairie
Margaret again no one thinks you know
Sense and Sensibility that's what I'm
talking about dude one of the best
movies is take a nap too in the history
the world prone sense and sensibility
and yeah lay down
even the voiceover of Sense and
Sensibility is a whisper Scorsese
directed Sense and Sensibility really
yeah that's a [ __ ] up yeah the [ __ ]
king of the gangsters also directed
Sense and Sensibility anyhow it was good
so as they were going Margaret well I
was on the ground Margaret great older
she's coming in for the kiss and the
last thing I heard was her she was a
great older yeah states should open your
mouth to me and then I opened my mouth
and then I was like oh this is weird you
just [ __ ] Tong Tong Tong same thing
do you think going back to that space
that you open your mouth
and you open your eyes wider at the same
time when they said that just out of
like some weird like no I think my eyes
might have been closed
oh yeah I think my eyes were closed and
they were like you got to open your hey
guy you gotta open your mouth because
this isn't gonna be anything if you
don't know but I don't think they were
like clamped yeah I just think that they
were not it was not kissing they were
not hi kisses hey buddy
hey guy nose buddy color man we got it
look I we feel awful
all right question number four see Oh
what is it and do you think Thea knows
the answer does Theo know what a
carburetor is and does yes yes you do is
gonna say I think this is the sort of
thing I expect you to know but if you
told me you didn't like because you're a
carburetor I feel like I feel like a
carburetor takes heat off of the engine
what do you think Nick I have no idea
does it have smoke in it I'm looking at
carburetor I like that you're trying to
think of the times you've heard it
people talk about it yeah a carburetor
is a device that mixes air and fuel for
internal combustion engines in the
proper fuel yeah I don't know that carb
you gotta use it cold and look what they
call in Australia you'll like this what
a car be a carving of course because
it's Australia they put a why on the
back of everything I met a guy from
Australia the other day that car B yet
so carburetor all right so that I bet a
lot of people are surprised you didn't
know because I didn't really know and I
still don't even know that I know what
it is I'm like I don't really know what
that is it feels like it's part of the
engine yeah it sounds like it is that
carburetor boy it is part of the engine
but I don't I let's not count that one
oh I'm counting okay count it so you did
know the Bears you didn't know Spike Lee
you did know California you did not know
what
carburetor is okay here's one okay wilfy
oh no what aids is an acronym for I
think you will I'm gonna go with
autoimmune deficiency syndrome that is
correct amino autoimmune either one is
right Nick
acquired but autoimmune it's fine do you
uh-huh
did you ever think you had AIDS and got
tested for it no I mean other people
think I have it really I'm look at me
I've never think AIDS no I know like
some lesser like well you're not
full-blown I don't think maybe that you
had a neighbor that had polio that's it
yeah I never know but you remember
having sex in the 90s it was like a it
was you it was scary yeah well there was
a live here think about it like really
think about aids more than I think about
STDs now you would think am I gonna die
from this
oh I remember being so angry at somebody
when I was young and I told people they
had AIDS
mmm-hmm how old like Heights grade
school high school I sounded out
probably graduate school it's 29 Wow
were they funny bro I don't want to know
any follow-ups I don't want to know
anymore
it's how do they how do they ever
confront you about it huh no man it's
not funny and I hope that they're doing
good - is there something interfering
with you or a happiness with your joy
with that sunshine getting inside of
your body and just bouncing off inside
of you is there something that's
preventing you from achieving your goals
maybe you uh maybe you came out of a
relationship and it's been heavy maybe
you had a hamster transaction go south
and you got the bad end
the ham well better help is here to help
better help will assess your needs and
match you with your own licensed
professional therapist that's right you
can start communicating in under 24
hours with a licensed therapist it's not
a crisis line it's not self-help it is
professional counseling done securely
online you know I had an instance one
time I was going in for an audition
actually and I was really really
struggling I was stressed and and and I
needed some therapeutic some help next
thing you know I'm on better help I'm
patched in and before you know it I'm
having a face time with my therapist she
pretty much told me to stop being a
little yeah but you know what I'm saying
it can be for something small like mine
or something big something heavy there's
a broad range of expertise and better
helps counselor network which may not be
locally available in many areas I know a
lot of you listening or you know you may
live in areas where you know going to a
therapist or being seen walking into a
therapy session is uncomfortable for you
well with better help therapy comes to
you you can log into your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor better help wants you to start
living a happier life today visit their
website and read their testimonials that
are posted daily just visit better help
calm slash t-h-e oh that's better eh
ELP and join the over 500,000 people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional and just for this past
weekend listeners you get 10% off your
first month at better help calm slash th
e oh if you need help get it look I
don't know what you're listening on
right now some people you might be
listening on a on a headset headphone
you might be listening on a xylophone a
speaker radio speaker well I've got the
way
you need to hear this past weekend
that's right I'm talking about rake on
earbuds rake on earbuds started about
half the price of any other premium
wireless earbuds on the market and their
newest model the everyday e25 earbuds
are their best ones yet with over six
hours of playtime seamless bluetooth
pairing more bass and a more compact
design that gives you a nice noise
isolating fit be unique everyone needs a
great pair of wireless earbuds but
before you go dropping hundreds of
dollars on a pair you need to check out
these wireless earbuds from Ray Khan
unlike some of your other Wireless
options ray con earbuds are stylish and
discreet no dangling wires or stems to
distract anyone during video calls
just yesterday I ran for probably about
maybe maybe two miles but the whole time
I was catching sound through my rake on
earbuds they stayed in they stayed with
me made me feel healthy made me feel
like the volume was right there and now
now you can get the latest and greatest
from Ray con get 15% off your order
at buy rakin dot-com slash th EO now
these are already great priced earbuds
and you're gonna get 15% off
that's Bui RA Y Co in.com slash th EO
for 15% off recon wireless earbuds by
rake on.com slash Co what about this
though I wanted to ask you this actually
is do you do you water or we talk ain't
maybe braids I look like I've do oh I'll
tell you this
so whenever ya in my twenties I had
pretty heavy erectile decided severe
anxiety was what I had sexual anxiety so
man I would get like you do you have do
you still have sexual anxiety or you
have still have it no
Rosie's like still have it like I still
get like yeah like I still definitely
have like some issues like if I get in a
relationship for me to want to have sex
if I'm in a relationship that kind of
thing like and do you have you like
talked to a therapist oh yeah they're
tired of hearing about it honestly what
do you what do they think it is fear of
intimacy
yeah probably fear of venomous ages but
it's not like performance like I'm not a
man or I'm not gonna be good at it or
not I don't think it's that yeah yeah
and when I was younger I just didn't
know what it was I just knew that I was
just super super nervous and so I
remember going to the doctor one time
and saying look I just want to make sure
that I know that this is just in my head
or if it's in my body
right does this remind me of the story
you tell about your buddy yeah so they
gave you an injection this man and this
guy was a complete [ __ ] I think if
you're gonna inject something to
somebody's penis yeah that's yes have a
little bedside manner little um yeah
this guy was a lollipop or of story or
something yeah knock I was like that
monkey on the Donkey Kong just [ __ ]
home in barrels this guy not care at all
right like he'd throw a barrel of
softener at a dick on a ladder you know
like this guy just I mean here's what
they did they inject something into your
penis and they say that it's going to
it's gonna get hard for a while and and
then you have to just monitor and let
them know like how long it stays hard
for and and you basically just stay in
this rough state in this room for like
six hours and it was the scariest thing
ever man and did you have a boner the
whole time yeah I do boner the whole
time and yeah it starts to get gets kind
of discolored and you're like what is
going on you get scared it hurts yeah it
does it's just too much blood trying to
get out of your penis it's like all your
blood wants to it's almost like trying
to like your blood is like trying to
have a bloody nose but it's in but it
can but it can't and it's like it just
man it hurts so bad but I need to find
out yeah it's nothing physical you don't
have any physical are you not supposed
to jerk off did he did he give you a
direction on that and I can't remember
it was too painful to to masturbate wow
that's interesting
yeah
the injection was just to make sure that
blood that the blood flow was working
yes so it was like okay we're gonna see
how long these like things in your penis
blood tanks or whatever will stay full
and uh oh dude it was so scary and the
guy was so mean and I was just not -
you're supposed to be not I guess no but
it's if you're dealing with dick stuff
it seems like like you know be a be
humane about it yeah because it's at end
for a guy it's like it was scary it's
it's like a it's a it's a cause of fear
and like vulnerability yeah and I was
floor I was at flirting with that way I
mean I'm always flirting with you ever
yeah you know I'll flirt with everybody
but oh man but that yeah that was
miserable but it did help me realize
okay it's nothing physical in my body
yeah so there's nothing my bodies were
you relieved if there was a physical
like that took off a ton of okay has
that has had no idea I'm always like
maybe I'm not stretching enough yeah I'm
not having enough lemonade you know just
anything yeah it comes like I don't know
if I can have that it'll clog my dick up
you know
oh geez a cheesecake no way you know if
this is probably for Google so it's just
all her mouth Google just be anybody it
could be any [ __ ] yeah Google was
just a anyone you were talking to was
good an older relative was absolutely
yeah well then there it is that's my
there's my answer
oh it's just kids so like I don't know
man but anyway so that was relieving
just to know that but what have you go
down on women or do something to to kind
of take the focus off of you or to push
oh the focus I would give anything man I
would be like oh I gotta go you know run
something at you anything anything to
kill time so people want the [ __ ] you
know and I don't have to be one of those
people even not wanted to be one of
those people would you start
would you like get would you would you
ever do the thing where you give them an
orgasm and then you like oh you know
what
I'm not we don't have to worry about me
no that's been later in my life like I'm
not into it like ejaculating or anything
like that like that's kind of I don't
really do that anymore like if I'm doing
sex I'm not doing
I'm more I'd rather not ejaculate now I
feel like it's almost it's more
avant-garde or something or more not on
my guard but this is where I go I have
no idea what you're gonna say there you
go
now ejaculating and I'm like what's all
that we could say anything well I want
to be on that you know I'm always trying
to think of like you know just I don't
know coming on somebody seems
old-fashioned we talked about this the
other day didn't me or Jack you late
none if somebody just seemed so like oh
it's so it's a movie yeah it's like
caveman it's like a jacket your own
house yeah yeah or something like get
out what are you doing
yeah go in there we're going to go to
the bathroom what do ya your penis has a
problem yeah like why would you what
it's happening yeah it is so graphic and
so like it's crazy because women just
like you know shake yeah whereas we have
a deliverable we have a new thing like a
look at this thing I have a thing a
third thing now I conjured this thing up
I've seen that but yeah man that stuff
it was always tricking me and the worst
thing is is figuring out like being
sexually comfortable for me anyway the
toughest thing it's just you're like man
I want to figure this out but then time
keeps ticking and you're like I'm in
after really a hundred percent figured
out in this life you know yeah yeah
that's the that's a funny thing where I
don't we talked about this last time but
it's like ya know maybe I don't get
married hey that doesn't happen for me
maybe there's not enough time in life
for me to crack that 80 years I just
it's a hundred and ninety year problem
yeah
it's a hundred ninety-eight riddle and I
just can't I don't have time I'm never
gonna there's no point in starting cuz
I'll never saw it's not solvable yeah
for ya that sometimes I think that about
certain things like especially when it
comes to like kind of relationships and
that comfortability and that sort of
thing and yeah and the NMC relationships
for me I'm just like
man at a certain point I don't want to
endanger anybody else's feelings that's
exactly dude that's and I don't know if
we talked about this before that's
exactly the point it's when guys guys do
the most damage when they think they can
be good like I know I'm a normal healthy
person meanwhile you're like no you're
not yeah in the back of your head you're
like you're [ __ ] not normal and
healthy yeah but you're like no I want
to be the kind of guy who seems normal
and healthy and you know just not and
then they ruin women's lives
yeah cuz women want to believe it and
then was it he's done it women and you
did he get married no I kind of am at
the moment and are you any good at it
yes I'm work all the time so it helps
yeah yeah but we don't have any gifts
for it so it's true yeah that's my beer
or maybe some guys do I will say I don't
have many and sounds like you don't have
many yeah I think it's really tough for
me I think that's one of the reasons
like sometimes I like spent on my
ex-girlfriend because it's just we at
least like get along well and it's easy
yeah and the expectations are manageable
the expectations are manageable and I
care about it's like and it's not like
we don't have like a real sexual law
there's not that element in our
relationship right so it's just like a
friendship really yeah and so it's like
I almost start to think sometimes I
don't know maybe this is crazy to think
but it's like maybe I just would get
married to a friend or something and
just you know well then you're into do
you need a companion because there been
times during this this kovat where I've
been like man I'm glad no one was here
this whole time right like or I'll be
here I'll be like someone would have had
a girlfriend would have been here the
whole time and would be with me right
now
yeah and I would and I wouldn't be
escapable yeah you just can't and that's
where I'm like I'm not I don't think I'm
built like that I don't need a companion
so a lot of people do I don't think I do
from what I can tell but do you think
you would like to challenge it because I
think that to for myself sometimes it's
like okay
sometimes I think well then maybe I have
divided my willing to challenge myself
enough but what see a challenge it's
like it's like see if I can just be like
yo can I get through it yes I can get
through something about that though
there's something about some guy seeing
some guy you know right before he dies
and his wife's right there and he's like
yes you know there's some element of
life like I respect that guy when I see
that guy dude and his wife is saying
something and he hadn't heard of her for
12 years you know because he's hurt at
all he knows what it is yeah you know
yes so there is a level of likewise just
salute that guy yeah absolutely
do you salute her no if it's if the if
the if the places are traded if she's in
bed she's in a telling deathbed and he's
been a loyal husband I mean I think I
mean yeah I think it's great what she's
doing you know but I think the women
salute her you know like I only I guess
something is specifically from a mate
you know like well but that's the thing
of like the men sometimes it's not hard
to be around women but like we don't
have a ton in common
just like naturally like where we did
that stuff we talked about the way we
deal with each other like men [ __ ] with
each other constantly oh yeah
and we're interested in different [ __ ]
like women generally don't love violence
the way we do they don't love
competition this is whatever there's
something like a lot of significant
differences there are a lot of ways in
which we do line up but then there's a
lot where we don't so I don't sometimes
I find that I can't the good stuff isn't
worth the bad stuff meaning this stuff
where it's like butting heads isn't
worth the like nice parts sometimes it
is sometimes it is but it's like it it
so I I can get through this I've stayed
in relationships I didn't what shouldn't
have stayed in oh yeah because of like I
wanted to make a [ __ ] effort yeah
[ __ ] get in there and roll yeah like
I [ __ ] you did it back in there yeah
they [ __ ] put throw the quarter yeah
however my [ __ ] base yeah I can do it
but it doesn't mean I should and that's
the thing that bothers me about kind of
societal norms is like you should it's
admirable
why doesn't mean it's just a thing that
I got through it's not a thing that why
do you want me to do a thing I don't
really enjoy right but then I want right
I agree I wish I enjoyed it
there's my I'm also saying I wish I
enjoyed it more I wish I was an easier I
wish I had an easier person there's
something also thin about being part of
but I don't know but I agree and then I
think like but then also there's
probably somebody that you know needs to
be loved out there and I could do my
best to help them you know what I love
them you know and then I think like you
know there's billions of people that
need to be loved by you right so then if
you could just get one you know yeah get
him in the house you read together
sometime no I know but then it just
becomes like a bird he's getting a bird
I mean your mother's Birds you're in an
iguana that's fine
I think some relation feel like that I
think some of them let's you guys are
each other's pets almost in a way yeah
you know I think at my Rodney you know
yes where is he the way they talk about
men is like that where like see and I do
see what I did and I got him a shirt and
I got an addition he's been dead for a
month but there's something though it's
it's but getting up being alone being
alone isn't funny there are a lot of
times a long long term I think it gets
lamer though as we get further into our
lives I think it gets lamer and
sometimes you're like can you still
relate to people as much or you just
that bad eye problem it's like that
thing in your homosexual as well they or
you know there's gay Randall or well
yeah he can you know his wife you know
he don't have a wife they yeah they
don't put illegal hang on if you're
married to a woman rightly collects
little pictures of men yeah yeah no
that's the joke I was I did a joke about
as a woman don't give you any if you I'm
46 I've never been married women are
like
this guy's a maniac oh yeah you're
getting into that freaking yeah [ __ ]
mate how are you I am 40 years old yeah
you're welcome to it I'm 40 I'm gonna be
41 yeah next year yeah so like I'm in
the [ __ ] I'm in the like the I used
to look like women would give me more
credit if I'd been married and murdered
my wife
yeah then having never been married like
something's the matter with you
yeah most of my uh the biggest thing I
feel like I want I just want to
apologize to any women that I've ever
been in relationship I think what we're
trying to say here is sorry yeah I just
met you're a decent I bet you're like my
nice are you not know yeah I think that
I am I'm mostly nice I mean I have like
I have a like jagged personality but I'm
not
no young saturation disorder though
definitely what like like I remember my
first girlfriend like she she you know
kind of bang some other guy and uh I
remember uh putting air in her shampoo
huh and uh like I was you know yeah I
was looking I was headhunt you know and
I'm gonna start with the hair you know
just yeah just angry or like bad well
that I know it's out of our lure went I
mean that's that's I don't think you
would have done that for no reason yeah
I think I was young too yeah you know
that's some of that say young yeah like
you don't know what else did you think
that's well now I have to put an air in
her shampoo yeah like naturally this is
how this ends yeah this is that's the
that's the logic yeah this ends with her
looking like a little bit of did she and
abuse and I like uh not doc wherever
something I was thinking of but um she
didn't one of her roommates used it but
uh she was fine hmm and I didn't know
now I didn't know anything about I mean
there's such a strong smell they can
tell instantly oh god I've never I don't
know what it smells like it's not like
burn like chemically it smells like like
it's nice but but that somebody could
really get hurt that's what it smells
like it smells like oh wow this is kind
of cool but then you're like oh this
could be really dangerous
I had a Theo thought one time
where I was thinking and I was like I
should give this to Thea where I was
thinking about sex like the smell of sex
afterward oh yeah and I had thought
smells like people been doing arts and
crafts oh yeah yeah and then I thought
that I should give that to feel with
their body duh yeah been making some
arts and crafts did you ever
I don't know I'm talking all this today
but did you ever feel like one of your
underarm smelled like vagina sometimes
did that ever come near well but this is
another question that was good how
what's the longest you've gone on the
kovat without taking shower and what how
bad did it get oh nothing too crazy I
would say maybe 72 hours probably if I'm
not feeling good I'll have to go back to
sleep and restart my day that's why I'm
one of those kind of people like I have
to take a nap like if I get real angry
or anything have to take a nap and
that's kind of restart my day basically
our old selves in timeout but if I can't
do that if I can't ball back and sleep
I'll take a shower okay and so that'll
get me it's like a recalibration 72
that's three days yeah I would say three
days casual what do you think Nick for
me personally I shower every day I love
showering it starts my day it's really
Chancellor yeah I wait I think I went
four days during kovat and it smelled
like smelled like Wrigley Field after
the seventh-inning stretch
bathroom the long urinal if you've been
to Wrigley Field but you said like
trough urinal oh yeah family-style yep
and that's what it smelled like yeah and
then that was on the bottom up top I
would say it smelled like it a beautiful
beautiful mysterious right there there
it is not the ivy I love that you could
eat out of those yes wonderful
that's it salad it's a salad bar that's
a that's a buffet that's for photo
and up top it smelled like someone was
making soup oh yeah but no one was
making soup yeah I was that beefy smell
sometimes yeah worth like onions and but
you ever had that you ever notice one of
your underarms and be like oh wow that
smells like a went like a female's kind
of yeah I mean I think it's the same
dynamic which is closed up close very
wet yeah close up yeah I mean they yeah
they add another element yeah yeah but
yeah that's interesting because I always
thought I was the only person and I
can't tell anybody this always felt like
that's this crazy secret that I had like
a vagina under like or like I was
supposed to be a woman you don't say I'm
like when ya long you think like oh my
god yeah I know there's like a woman
trapped under my arm yeah or sorry you
know just crazy [ __ ] yes of course um
all right you guys make anything else
good hold on oh okay I believe you're
gonna know this name two books by Ernest
Hemingway oh I know this one what did
the audience thing kind of told me I
would I would have guessed yes I think
he knows literature quite a bit actually
I hear some some crazy references pulled
out and I'm gonna go with Sun Also Rises
and Moby Dick Heffron he did not write
Moby Dick I have the same series yeah I
had the same thought and I can't
remember who wrote one of his friends
write it who wrote it oh man I can't
remember either it is Herman Melville do
you want and littered you want to guess
a different one Hemingway no I just knew
that one they had us right read in high
school Ernest Hemingway I never really
liked him anyway man I thought it was
good I think Muriel's pretty hot but I
never I haven't read any of it you
haven't no it was always a little I
don't know sure I like the short
sentences he was like super into like
outdoorsy guy [ __ ] right yeah yeah yeah
yeah and he was all Marines basically
yeah this is kind of early
I guess alright we did not surprise
sorry folks he did not know this one I
think you're gonna know name three songs
can you name three songs by Def Leppard
let me think about it
Def Leppard uh-huh I would say no puck I
would have guessed you did I would have
guessed
I'll just say cherry pie that's I was
gonna say that's warrant
that's warrant yeah that's warm broad
[ __ ] love warrant here we got the old
man in the sea for Whom the Bell Tolls
that's those are not Def Leppard songs
those that is Hemingway books in our
time Sun Also Rises fair what arms to
heaven having out for Whom the Bell
Tolls the old man in the sea what do you
think I have a question then what do you
think how do you think comedy looks
after this where do you think we go from
here I don't know I mean different
theory I've never had been where people
are like people were saying early like
the comedy middle class is gonna be
[ __ ] like people that are open mic or
it's at work day jobs we find cuz they
can and then like headliners will be
okay I don't know if anyone's gonna have
to stop doing stand-up do you know what
I mean like I don't think anyone I don't
know how many clubs are gonna shut down
completely but so you just headlined
fewer clubs I guess well yeah I mean
there's few there's less money coming in
I mean we had Rambo on I don't know yes
I think that there will be less money
but I don't think it'll be you can no
longer be a comedian
I think you can still make a living
doing it it'll it for some people it
will be a worse living but I don't know
I was supposed to start a show in New
York like a one-man show may 5th Wow and
had the theater everything and then just
gone
do you I mean I can't help but it's
interesting because you can find an
airplane yep but you can't sit in a
venue you know well that's what the the
I've read yesterday I think 50 percent
of Ja like hospitality and live events
is down 50 percent employment so half
the people are unemployed but then
there's I've read another thing where
they there are venues like 300 Cedars
are basically saying to headliners like
headliner headliners like there's a
place called City Winery in New York
there's like eight of them there's like
a in different cities it's basically a
live music venue or performance venue
they they basically said the headliners
like we could have 80 people in here and
you can charge whatever you want so
there are there are certain acts that
are thinking like I could church 300
bucks a ticket right and if it's 80
people that the gross is 20 for grant
right maybe I can walk with 14 or what
you know I mean like something or you
get the hold or like it if you if you
have fans that can pay a lot of money
you could do shows tomorrow right you
just have to charge people a lot of
money Yeah right - in order to enforce
social distancing you're gonna but I
once there's a let's say there's a
vaccine in a year I think it goes more
or less how it was I don't like you know
I seem right what do you think I think
so I think yeah I think you get back to
I mean I think you know some of the
clubs are opening up they had a hundred
people in 125 people and the ones that
in Oklahoma City and and uh in Salt Lake
City I just wonder if they're gonna you
know if that works I can't see them
after you know a couple of weeks not
sliding in an extra table here they're
you know we're like yeah I mean a little
bit of that's gonna happen so you're
gonna increase that there will there be
raids or will people I I had the thought
and I and I'm I'm fairly sure I'm not
certain about much and kovat
there's not gonna be another lockdown
meaning once this lockdown is over
they're not gonna be able to do another
one right I don't I just don't think
people are gonna go for it yeah I don't
know if because I think now I think
people are like okay we did that we
tried to flatten the curve yeah I think
now too many people just don't know what
to believe there's that I also think
even if there's a second wave in the
fall I think you're not gonna be able to
shut the country down I just don't I
think people are gonna be like nah man
we did it we gave we did three months
right of a worse life for almost
everybody I have worse like for
everybody it's a worse life right it's
more a different life yeah it's but I
think for a lot of you it's people are
even I'm not that social I still wish I
could go work and do stew socialize
right yeah I don't think people are
gonna go for it again I think it'll be
some of it on the right will be we don't
believe you and some on the Left will be
like ah come on man like we did it once
the economy is on life support
yeah and so that's the I think that this
if there is a second wave I think it's
gonna be every man for himself I think
people are just gonna be like there you
go you and Shaw I'm always self what do
you think you like that Nick I don't
know if you you could completely
quarantine and not leave your house if
that's the fear if you're older that's
like Dom's 87 yeah
and I've had to like yell at her and be
like look stay home like well I know
know you're 87 there's a if you get Cova
over 80 there's a 20% chance yeah that's
a [ __ ] Rappaport right there yeah now
having said that there was a guy show
the picture of the guy who was at Miami
Music Festival and he almost he was
ripped it was on BuzzFeed news
he was yoked and then he and then he got
was it Arenberg this guy was on steroids
wow that's funny I didn't think about
that I'm so naive
yeah probably if you don't get steroids
for a while especially during
this thing then you gotta know if you do
Miami yeah I think this I went to high
school with this kid named Chris I think
is that him what's this guy's name
yeah that god is he done any steroids
left I've seen this kind of [ __ ] and it
if you completely stop lifting you don't
you don't eat you dehydrate don't like
it can so he was in he was in like
intubated for six weeks and he thought
it was a week Wow
yeah he's like said to the nurse I'm
about like a so it's been a week she's
like a week you've been here six weeks
living off the frickin government's dime
this bastard just laying there in a coma
bro wake up man bro yeah you gotta get
back out of it straps at bro he went
from you to me basically [ __ ] poor
guy
holy o Nation dude it was 26% of his
body weight in six weeks that's it's a
lot yeah but that's what I was saying
like it's gonna be every man for himself
I was joking on the way over here for
that there should be you know like the
NFL Combine yeah that should just be
like if you can run the 40 and under
eight seconds you're good to go
like you can you're good do you like
people on the starting line with their
bug I jump just like are you fit enough
yeah he'll be alright the chances are
you're gonna be fine yeah that anti but
I cuz I truly don't believe they're
gonna be able to do it again I don't
think I think enough businesses will be
like I'm not gonna have a business yeah
I think there's like a quarter
businesses are [ __ ] anyhow well a lot
of people are operating mums in the deal
I go to a trainer and see a trainer on
the DL you know like and it's you know
they have a curtain in front of them you
know yeah right knee so nobody could see
yeah I know people are getting like
secret haircuts back-alley haircuts yeah
I ain't got one yesterday at a garage
over in Reseda some enough Twitter
really yeah that's so funny
so I had to finish it up myself a little
bit she she didn't do bad but she didn't
do great but what do you think about the
Joe Rogan deal there I am right there in
that garage and Reseda man I've rolled
in her and her husband do it that's so
goddamn funny
pretty good
give her a nice tip I felt like and they
were her husband has two kids that he's
divorced but he has two kids that moved
to the town I'm from actually in
Louisiana and they're living over there
how old are they
I'm not of age I mean the daughter
sounded hot but she's young you know but
that's what the lady said I didn't say
that I don't even ask
rogon I think it's [ __ ] awesome I
think it's what do you think it's gonna
do what do you think it's gonna do well
we talked about this on the phone I
don't think it's gonna do much me I
think it's good I think it's
unequivocally good cuz the like when
Howard Stern went from radio to
satellite it was almost like he left
popular culture whereas Jo podcast is
already not it's already like off the
beaten path so I think he's not gonna be
reduced culturally at all right like
there's not he's not gonna miss I don't
I don't know how much that means to him
anyway but I don't he's not gonna be any
less relevant culturally and it sounds
like a lot of money and with very little
downside it's like his listeners have to
listen to ads I think this subscription
if you don't want to listen to ads yes
Ames YouTube yeah yeah it seems like he
I mean he's like the guy to do it cuz he
got like you said he got everything he
wanted he's licenses so he's not giving
up IP he can still put out YouTube clips
which is like his biggest growth more
people watch his clips than his full
episodes on YouTube anyways yeah I don't
see I don't see the downside people are
like oh Spotify might be able to control
them a I think that's why they don't
want to control I mean he's the reason
he's popular is cuz he talks about 10
things like you know I mean I don't
think they're gonna be like could you
just focus on UFOs yeah like it's just
they're not gonna and also once if he
feels like if he even sniffs like
they're trying to control him he'll just
go [ __ ] this [ __ ] this I think that's
why I said [ __ ] this to YouTube because
they are doing some of that slightly
censorship thing I don't know whether
yeah I mean just like
if you talk about Corona they'll
demagnetize you yeah and I think that
kind of stuff could just be getting
stronger you know as we go along it
definitely seems like on Twitter it's
like extremely it's a very liberal app
it seems like you know like so I think
that and you know I think that I could
see some of the other you know the
Giants some of the other social media
Giants and YouTube's almost it's really
kind of like social media in a way I
mean it's but I'm curious to see what
Spotify new interface is gonna look like
because if they're gonna start video and
they don't have as full episodes and
then are they gonna buy other stuff to
supplement it because you go there might
a promise you they're gonna ask you
Schultz
Sandra you know I'm sure they've already
asked / Obama does Obama have a deal at
Spotify that's a rumor that I heard yeah
yeah so yeah like I'm sure they've
already asked / I'm sure they've already
asked like didn't I mean they Bill
Simmons they gave him a million like
they gave him a normally I think it was
a hundred yeah I think 150 but the
difference there they bought the ring or
actually right Joe Roby just licensed it
right but they also pay Amy Schumer she
show Joe Budden yeah yeah Joe Budden so
like though though you know I think
they'd rather have more than less
there's no downside I mean I button like
a lot of my podcast is streams on
Spotify like I don't Joe wouldn't give
it to them I think right and yeah I
don't think I mean and they're gonna
license oh I guess at a certain point
he'll be able to get it all back yeah
will will they take everything he has on
YouTube and put it on to Spotify
the full episodes yes and it's gonna be
like a slow transition okay so it's been
yeah so he's got a huge library's got
6,000 hours I would guess Wow
he's done maybe not 6,000 but definitely
3,000 yeah so I don't I think it's good
for both of them honestly their stock
went up 10% yeah
like the on the announcement like there
it's good that's all they wanted I
wonder what their platform is gonna be
like our people I mean it is time for
YouTube to have a competitor for sure
yeah you know that's the that YouTube's
gonna be hard to compete with because
they have a 15 year leave and I and
they're owned by Google and like they
just have a lot of [ __ ] going for them
yeah but yeah that's the that's the I'm
I'm happy for Joe and it seems like
there's no downside I'm and I that if
that's a smart investment on their part
I said I think I said to you on the
phone the fact that Comedy Central or a
network never got a bunch of podcasts
video podcast and just put them on
Comedy Central at 10:30 the way he used
to put Howard Stern on is back it's
still baffling to me yeah still because
you look at the amount of hits if we get
you'd be like those better numbers than
Comedy Central numbers yeah so why would
you guys and I think it's because they
didn't feel like they did it yeah like
love line at night remember even in
heaven love line on that was like having
a podcast basically just sitting there
and that was that was kind of a pop that
was a popular show up yeah but love line
was the like a produced version of the
radio show I don't even think they
needed to do all that yeah they could
have what people don't realize is this
is enough yeah this is enough they used
to I mean it Howard Stern used to show
it then they acted like well that didn't
happen and then I guess I must did it on
TV on MSNBC it's gonna be I mean it's
definitely something gonna be
interesting I yeah I think for for Joe
it's really a no-lose he does licenses
you know you know he can have it back
I'm guessing whenever he leaves the
thing about Joe is he doesn't seem rich
right
even though he's and he's been rich and
now he's now it's like getting to like
wealthy yeah he doesn't see he just
doesn't hasn't really changed he hasn't
he looks he looks like he'd look if he
worked construction yeah almost to the
outfit
like I done enough difference which is
part of his appeal he just doesn't
that's his sensibilities like t-shirts
and jeans yeah and a pocket full of
fresh hawk me what about the Comedy
Central hey could you pull up Andres
Holtz's video for about Comedy Central
please on his Instagram I love this
Schultz
call me on the way I'm here he did yeah
how's he doing good yeah yeah he's
always good huh yeah he's got a good
disposition yes he does God lucky
bastard precentral got fired last week
oh I heard like every executive car be
central got fired last week
that's that's Takashi right there that's
crazy man yeah I mean we're talking
about a yesterday they have passed on so
many I mean I like yeah and I've never
understood like why they wouldn't just
give people the benefit meaning sign
people to like a three-year deal and go
just come up with a show for yourself
yeah and you can they go alright we'll
shoot it and then they're gonna do
another one do another one do another
one
like just if you're I have a theory that
that they didn't ever really like the
shows that were hits for them like yeah
they didn't like South Park they found
crass Tosh Tosh they didn't like yeah
it's just Freddie
what they call Freddie yeah like off
what is this junk yeah that's what's
paying your salary yes that's the [ __ ]
that keeps like review and and Nathan
for you don't make money
Tosh [ __ ] makes money Chappelle show
makes money they thought they'd I think
they didn't like the they didn't like
the tone it's just not like
sophisticated and buttoned up so it
wasn't a daily show was kind of created
in-house Doug Herzog who was the
president was like we should do like a
Sports Center for the news right so that
and and they love John and that's a big
moneymaker and and Colbert was a [ __ ]
great show too like both very good shows
and very profitable for them and then
but there now they had all the people
there had nothing to do with them so
they want to make sort of more sad City
and they want to make whitey Keppler
whatever that show was yeah they picked
up some it's like what is this it made a
lot of stuff that I felt like was ain't
like very leftist you know they didn't
say in the middle of the road at all
well they're not in the middle of the
people that work there are not middle of
road so that's what I'm saying they
think Tosh is Friday and Chappelle shows
kind of Freddie and and South Park's
kind of Friday like they don't crazy
yeah
understand that that you would I don't
know I just it makes me mad cuz only
there's so many times and pitch them so
many things I spent a year developing
this really great project with them that
I think I'm probably getting up
releasing on YouTube you know it just
burns me up sometimes Manson yeah I did
a televised Mormon and they didn't pick
him up and I was always like you don't
want to just pick it up just cuz of
Chappelle show just maybe just me I
don't know [ __ ] maybe I maybe I maybe
I'm good luck or something I am all I
always do well like I did an hour on
their network get rated really well yeah
they just I I don't I think certain
people they just don't they like who
they like and they don't like who they
don't like
yeah and there's nothing you can do
about it well they always think if girl
wants to sleep with you or not and you
can't be like don't you look at this tie
it does I don't care i-i've already
decided right and they make their mind
up they like sophisticated alternative
Williamsburg II but Silver Lake II
that's their that's their the people who
works there's personality yeah and so
you seem cry you're like southern what
well then at a southern personal in the
network I can never since when you know
it's just so messed up because you know
they say they're like oh we want to you
know we want to put alternative voices
and this and that but it's like to get
from you know a place in like a small
town in the south to get here and then
to be able to continue to like you know
weave your way through this place and
then you get to a level where you
finally have some opportunity and they
say oh no this isn't for you it's like
do you now [ __ ] hard it was to do
this yeah like just well bad I mean the
good news it's not really progressive
it's like progressive is you know I
don't know it's high it's it is too
because like precip should just be the
funniest people but then they would get
in trouble in the press and amongst
their peers for not being more for not
being more representative and [ __ ] like
that like so it just comes down to like
I told
this one time I was like why people
don't make black movies cuz they don't
they go to a cocktail party make it a
black movie doesn't give you any cachet
they're like Oh mmm like if you made if
you make like a Coen Brothers movie or
if you make like if you make No Country
for Old Men or Fargo that's and you go
to a cocktail party you're gonna [ __ ]
run that modify if you are you make a
Tyler Perry movie right if you make the
cupboard seven or whatever
yeah like so there's just no there's
like less incentive and that's like with
a lot of TV execs they don't that their
circle is all liberal snobs and that's
the thing I was saying to you on the
phone yet so it was like as a comic
because we're comics we travel all the
time and we see people killing who we
don't agree with
so we every night we get our point of
view like support it and not support it
so we know like arson yeah my point of
view is funny and I think it's right and
then I go on I talk my [ __ ] liberal
[ __ ] then you go on after me and do do
whatever I do do your thing you do as
well better around the same whatever so
I can't be like my point of view is the
only point like you can't as a comedian
I cannot think that cuz a I have to
travel to Dallas in Houston and Austin
and New Orleans and like places where
people are not like me right but how
closed-minded is it to act like those
people's sense of humor isn't relevant
like that's the crazy I just think that
they're biased and they don't even on
those people's sense of humor is less is
just less sophisticated and what I would
say is they're not they're obviously
it's some of it is but there's some dumb
white there's some like it's not all
[ __ ] Ernest goes to camp yeah and in
fact a lot
that's so old [ __ ] of course it'll have
it's almost like but by alienating a lot
of that part of the country you only
need a lot of great storytelling you
alienate you just alienate so much you
know yeah I just don't understand it so
now the good news is you can do your own
failed all your all the way to the bet
you know I mean like you failed you know
no one the it's hard because it's almost
like a marriage thing where we don't get
that like ceremony of success that's the
thing you little thing you want a
[ __ ] trophy and a party and a ha ha
ha and we'll never get like you won't
get press coverage for this you won't
get I think most people look at your
views or downloads and be baffled you
don't even like you'd be like what for
that for just that they don't understand
fused by it yeah so that's the great
thing about doing stand-up is like you
just go oh I'm not I'm like I'm me you
Joey Joe and Whitney could all go
back-to-back we all do around the same
as well and we all completely divergent
political points of view or cultural
points of view and that's what's [ __ ]
awesome about it
yeah and that's how their network should
be I feel like a lot of times or how it
should have been right they don't know
how to I think I told you that they
didn't know the Chappelle show when we
first started they would they would go
like this isn't they like wouldn't like
jokes or sketches and we're like can we
show it to the crowd do you mind yeah
and then we show it to the crowd and it
would kill and the first couple episodes
they were like well your crowd is an
hour crowd it was like what what what
are you talk it was just people with
biases yeah didn't want to believe that
this thing that they couldn't if they
didn't understand it and then finally
after six episodes they said we don't
understand it and you can kind of do
whatever you want because they didn't
mess it up man I mean it just to just
act like something doesn't exist yeah
it's almost the crazy thing yeah times
bias exists yes the most it's almost
worse to me than like a
it's a racism in a way it's like a it's
a classism it's a it's a it's it's like
cultural snobbery and its cultural
bigotry in a weird way
yeah like prejudging you because you
have a mullet and then you get your hair
cut in a garage I accept you yeah no no
but that's the thing it's like they
would go like what Baird you're like a
[ __ ] you're a [ __ ] you're a
[ __ ] Gator man or whatever the
[ __ ] what was the Gator [ __ ] like oh
this boys means you're so you're a Swamp
Thing like they're you're so far off the
but the good news is you can do this you
can invest a little bit of money in your
own cameras and your huh and you make
great money and you get the underdog
status that is its own reward like it's
more rewarding than you would actually
yeah you're like it is you'll feel like
everyone's rooting for you there's
always a little something you want that
wedding though there's always a line no
because I think I think you just want to
be told your very heart of the group
yeah that's the thing it's like it's the
thing of like oh you don't exist mm-hmm
it's like man that's how I felt most of
my life why I even had to [ __ ] start
telling jokes and then I get all the way
here to California yeah the place where
it's like come here if you feel like
this and I get there and it's not even
about feeling like that yeah it's not
about that really it's about oh it's
really
oh we determine if you are okay or not
you're like oh so this is exactly the
same thing that I did that I disprove
once is that you're telling that I left
this yes exactly the same thing that
ignited all this in me in the beginning
yes is that we we don't see you yeah
yeah seen by us you know and I think the
it's just no okay you know it is it's
like it's it's kind of painful and
unfair it is it's like and I don't they
it's a limited thing they have a limited
resource they only can show somebody
shut whatever I get that but as people
that feel like way we're sensitive
we work hard and it's very hard to and
do you have not the amount of times
I'm told you're invisible people would
be baffled by yeah you had one of the
biggest shows yeah but like I get so I
do big show
I'm talking about like in stand-up
anything in where it's like I big show I
do a big show and then do a Netflix
special its popular and good and then I
do a half-hour Netflix popular and good
and then like Dave Chappelle's getting
honored by the Kennedy Center and they
go will you write for this I'm like will
I write for it no not even a little bit
will I write for it it's just like this
constant heat-seeking and it's never
Merritt it's never just like I think
you're [ __ ] funny yeah it's just no
one's making any it's just weird it's
like yeah why would you spend your whole
life afraid to make a choice or have
people on that are like if you have a
show with podcasts whatever like just
have people on that you're [ __ ] good
instead of like mmm let me see how many
followers do you have
what's the worst and it became about
yeah I mean [ __ ] damn bruh you know yeah
and that's but that's what I like about
Joe's success is that he truly just did
the thing he liked like UFOs he liked
UFC he liked drugs he liked weed he
liked [ __ ] conspiracies he liked and
he just was like oh talk about that
let's get somebody is what comedy and it
just becomes like great and he had
people on based on I want to have you on
I don't know if you're popular I don't
know anything about you other than I saw
you and I thought you were good not like
mmm there's no calculation and there's
no like what you seem cold are using
like they they just were like you're
good
that's it full stop there you do well
you kill yeah that's what it's like
almost like the combine thing where I
almost feel like if you do a show and
you get laughs above a certain decibel
meter yeah you're good right you can do
you're allowed to do whatever you are
not anything you want but did you see
like well what's the it's just you
personally it's just you say no when
it's not based on [ __ ] anything yeah
other than your taste and your biases
yeah it's crazy it's crazy how you can
just I'd never felt more it was a couple
years ago man especially right when all
the trumps over whenever like the
political I remember you were like mad
for a year uh I just because I just like
man I was like man I'm work this is
where he's supposed to come if you want
to be open-minded and think about things
and you know and this is where and it
just wasn't that it was just a lie you
know yeah and it was like oh so you're
telling me that we don't judge people we
don't look at this but then that's
exactly what I worked so hard to get my
head out of the ground on Groundhog's
Day yeah well a lot of times it's like
people they don't they're not against
bullying they're not against racism
they're against bullying against them um
playing against racism against their
group or their they're not against it at
large so that's why these nerves turn it
on ya know I know I know it's like
that's why it's like I know I know and
you know I know yeah you know I know
what you're feeling and that's like like
I'm a like I was thinking on the way
over here like we're similar in that
word like not exactly of either thing
you're not exactly I'm sure people in in
Louisiana think you've a little
Hollywood and people in Hollywood think
your little Louisiana and you're like I
and I'm like a nerd but all the others I
think I'm a jock and all the jocks think
I'm a nerd I'm like and and the and
white people think I'm black yeah and
black people think I'm white and I'm
just like ah I and you end up feeling
isolated yeah and and it's like it's a
source of frustration frustration it's
also a source of though like I mean you
know I'm kind of wallowing in that a
little bit I'm almost getting into
self-pity a little bit but it's like
yeah it's also a source of like oh this
is what drugs probably always driven me
so in
thank I'm glad they that they served
another dose I'm glad that you have guys
like Schultz who are like I'm free
enough to say what I want you know yeah
but that's the great but the funny thing
is like all things comedy or any
podcasting network is gonna be more
valuable in Comedy Central in five years
yeah so as much as it's like it's just
one of those things of like you're
getting your 40 you see cycles now and
you're like oh [ __ ] okay that's
surprising but like I made a bunch of
money on DVDs what yeah what our DVD
like there's George Lucas made money on
VHS laserdisc DVDs and now digital like
you just have to stick around long
enough right to and if you're and I was
talking to a buddy of mine who's who's a
musician and by the way no one feels
like they've made it that's the other
thing I've learned is no one feels like
I'm on top of the world like they
everyone's like has a list of [ __ ]
grab grievances and people that [ __ ]
him over and and way things I'll they'll
never give me they'll never give me that
like everybody who's got who's a big
singer and he's trying to get a he's
like I need two more hits then they
can't say [ __ ] to me oh wow and you're
like you still and you I'll tell you
after who it is you'll be like that's oh
god no one feels like they've done
enough and no one feels respected enough
no one feels like legitimized enough
even though you know the most legitimize
people that's the good news now I would
say that you and I have a legitimate
grievance yeah I mean it's I think it's
just that thing I think it's and you
want to feel like you belong that other
thing is more than anything it's like
I'm mad I'm not on this you probably are
like I'm not mad but I'm my own here no
no but you know what I mean like I
there's all these colonists yeah and
you're like I don't I mean I know what I
no in the ways I'm not like these guys
and I know the way I am like but but we
all want to be in the right we all want
to be included yeah that's all we all
it's all we want at all yeah yeah like
we just want to be included and it's
hard and that's I think the thing that
liberals don't understand about
conservatives in the last five years
it's just like it's just been
they've just been excluded for so long
culturally and a bunch other ways that
it's like [ __ ] you this guy at least
cares
this guy's like me right more I mean now
having said that he's not at all like
Jared Kushner and [ __ ] though it's
there the wood they're worse than any
liberal you never meet but I'm saying
like like I get I get it I get the anger
and resentment you feel from being
excluded and looked past yeah that's the
thing I think just not being seen yeah I
think everybody feels that you think
Nick mmm-hmm everybody wants to be
included you know like I feel bad
sometimes we're doing an episode or not
on talked to Nick like I mentioned Nick
you know it's like yeah not because I
think Nick's sitting there thinking oh I
wish you would mention me but it's like
but you did you're a hypocrite if you
don't think that you're a hypocrite if
you're like we're not left right many of
our the lights on us good stay back
behind that glass monster Clutton if I
close the door the door the open doors
freaking me out a breath and get
underwater somewhere but no it's just
because I I know that everybody wants to
feel mentioned everybody wants to feel
yeah we just want to feel like a part of
something yeah which i think is one of
the reasons why people come out to LA a
lot of times because they maybe some
people anyway yeah they didn't fit in
where they wouldn't fit in they didn't
feel a part of something that they
didn't feel like yeah they had the full
feeling um yeah but I'm not I'm not
I get it and it's I'm like I heard
Nipsey Hussle one time I say this to
Dave and then Nipsey Hussle said a
version of it what I used to say to Dave
is like before Chappelle show like his
curves [ __ ] [ __ ] halfway came out
didn't do good did another mom who
didn't do good he was just like mad and
pissed off and like floundering kind of
and I was like York they'll they'll let
you back in but you're gonna have to
walk and they're not gonna give you a
ride they're not gonna make it easier in
any way and nipsey hussle said he's like
yeah I'll get I just have to take the
steps mm-hmm like you're not you just
get to the point we got I'm never gonna
be given there never you're never gettin
a wedding right I'm never getting a
wedding I will never get that like that
marriage ironic yeah I will never get
the marriage to I will never get I will
never feel the love and the acceptance
that I would get from being like I
auditioned and they said you're gonna
we're gonna put you on a show and then I
did a show and that was a hit and then I
decided eh I want to sing and then I
said like it knows it's not like a it's
like well yeah and people shits on you
like looking down at you and like it's
just never and it's the sewer man yeah
and all it does it just makes you more
empathetic and makes you and it makes
people root for you yeah I don't think
you will ever not that's the thing as
much as your you think your Sabinas is a
liability but it's not it's it was now
it's it's selling point yeah you know
like um well think that's a nice
compliment I think but I but it's but
it's also it's true it's like now I I
don't know why is great your listeners
or most of your most of your viewers are
but it's they're all over just regular
people really that's what I mean and
they're not it's not fancy it's not
fancy it's not Hollywood it's not like
it's also not premeditated yeah it's
like and so you see it as like for you
to be like that's [ __ ] swamp things
here and now it's like [ __ ] swamp
things yeah it's like goes from are like
the Rat King like this [ __ ] rat Kings
out here and now it's like [ __ ] Rock
but I come back soon man yeah people are
excited yeah dude we sold 70 Rhett it we
sell it with Tunnel Rat King shirts man
yeah
and it's fun being the Rat King - of
course and it's fun that the whole world
is turning into WWE man that's what I
think about like like we're talking
about like what's-his-name turning into
the heel Hulk Hogan you know and I have
one question so you and Dave Chappelle
you guys are on talking terms now right
yeah and what you guys were so for a
long time because what was that like you
guys who had a we were and it's okay we
were not we the way the show went
basically the way the negotiation after
this show got popular was just not like
good did you have a were you able were
you guys negotiating together with
Comedy Central or you guys were notion
ago she a ting separate kinda separately
right so we're and that's the problem
you know that's and I told them before
we started good you know they're gonna
play divide and conquer they have to pay
you they don't have to pay me so the
only way they'll pay me is if you make
them and then they would they played him
there it's just so many people come
between when something's popular it just
you just get layers of people that want
to seem more important and want to seem
like they're doing things for of course
to protect David who but it's not David
was Dave in that case but it's a bunch
of people it can be just [ __ ] and so
someone who actually is making the thing
they resent me
do you know main cause like they're just
they're not writing that directing it on
in the [ __ ] you mean like like an
executive like not executives like more
like lawyers agents man oh yeah they
resent you because you have to be
included because I'm Marty I do the show
right they're not I didn't just I don't
call and I make the show deej so good so
then that creates separation and then
and then he left and it was [ __ ] like
that added to it wasn't prized when he
left
I mean like in retrospect not really but
that's a pretty big swing yeah okay what
do you guys think yeah like going to
Africa is like that's pretty big like I
didn't see that coming although like it
that's exactly out of proportion
that's as out of proportion as the rest
of the show where it's like the most
popular [ __ ] and then like what's teach
leaving the show version of the Rick
James sketch going to Africa right not
telling anyone all right I'll do that so
there's that and then we didn't really
speak we spoke a little bit and then
since like we've been cool since like oh
seven yeah yeah I know you guys are I
know you guys have a have been for a
while did whenever you watch the last
dance did you think of yourself like a
Scottie Pippen at all of course yeah
I watch I mean I said it in frame I
sitting Scottie Pippen I was like it's
like being on team with Michael turn and
so it's funny seeing pip and get man
it's like I want to call him be like pip
there's nothing we can do yeah he's
going there's just nothing you can do
it's I'm gonna [ __ ] worry about how
to play for Birmingham yeah you know
yeah and there's nothing and also like I
gotta get my did it
they can't yeah the audience only
understands single they don't know no
one's ever been on like even when they
say a dream team one of them's better
yeah they always just like LeBron and D
Wade LeBron right capital LeBron smaller
D Wade or
LeBron and Anthony Davis like but the
mixture makes it of course right but and
then if your day but I don't want to
[ __ ] acknowledge a mixture with a
[ __ ] white person yeah you know I
mean and I get well you know what I mean
like yes and if you'd have been black do
you think that the show would have been
picked up for another season then well
it wasn't picked up it was picked up if
I do in black that's a really good
question
I don't it's impossible to know it would
have been a little now but then it yeah
it there's a different there would have
been different
if I were black there would have been
like a lot of the same ones and then a
it's a host of other ones that I'd
probably don't even realize right but
but no of course so it's like they don't
you watch it and you go yes can't even
[ __ ] great yeah it's just not as
great as yeah he shows up it's not as
good as if it's like the I that deal
that all the time like there was a there
was a I went on after Dave at the Comedy
Cellar one time and the the emcee was
like thanks guys co-creator Chappelle
show did it and I go and I go on I'm
like but Co greater Chappelle show was a
really good credit unless Dave just went
on and then it's nothing it's like it's
interesting unless the [ __ ] guy was
just here it's not there you're just
like oh so I get the it's just an
insurmountable I don't but I will say
I'm not I'm not jealous
I'm not really jealous of David mm-hmm
even Chris Rock said that one time he's
like you're just not jealous you're just
I don't like I'm Matt I have like
personal argument [ __ ] with Dave but I'm
not like I'm I should have been Rick
James yeah I'm like [ __ ] two very
different skills yeah and and so I'm
happy to be myself and and to the
underdog thing it is fun to climb out of
it yeah it's [ __ ] but sometimes I
look at my career and like this is a
[ __ ] miracle wow it's a miracle that
like I was a writer for a TV show that
was really popular and now I'm like kind
of famous comedian yeah that's [ __ ]
impossible like I wasn't a comedian and
then I like figured out how to do it and
like it's it's crazy yeah and I'm not
even like it suck my dick like I just
mean like right now I think about it I
you just get like objective you look at
your career objectively your life
objectively
you have to look at things yeah I mean
even looking back on on Chappelle can
you see like we see a just under you
think like looking back now and knowing
how we see like people get stressed and
the overwhelmingness of things do you
yeah I think it's just stress and I
think it's not it just once things are
not fun it's not and also once you're
talking about that much money and people
know how much money you're making and
it's on the cover of the paper and it's
like seeds they're not it's like yeah
it's it's it's like the difference I
said this to a basketball player like
there between a rookie contract and a
max deal rookie contract everyone feels
like they're even if you're the best
rookie they're like yeah you making five
million bucks
that's pretty [ __ ] good and then you
get your max - you're making 33 million
a year and they're like I don't know
what you're gonna do but it [ __ ]
better be good go go go
show me mr. 33 million dollars and it's
just a less fun position to be in
yeah which is the thing of having never
had a wedding
like you know we'll we'll never get I
don't think anyone will ever be like
okay mr. smartypants or whatever like I
don't think that that's the thing that
we may never have to deal with and that
which is good which is a good that's an
advantage that we don't have to we'll
have to deal with like it's not as good
as this last thing or any of that stuff
but it'll never be like I feel like Joe
somehow got around it I don't think
anyone resented him and I think it has
to do with his looks and clothes and
habits I don't think it's habit yeah
this happens - he lists people up a lot
you know yeah he does I feel like
include people a lot yeah so that's the
but I don't
but like you know me and Dave argued
about it for six hours like three weeks
ago
really oh that's fine it's [ __ ]
hilarious
it's Hilaire it's so interesting but
yeah what I mean what a comment cuz ya
like to think that it to go then to
Comedy Central and they won't give you a
new show and then you're like wow I mean
you had to feel well they wanted me to
produce black sketch shows that I can do
til I die they'll give me please
yeah you got blank check for that but
I'm like I don't want not what I wasn't
even it was a black sketcher but it was
more just as show about Dave it wasn't
like and then black something black will
happen somebody do blackness and so yeah
it is
I don't get many opportunities they
there's just people have a bias against
me and that I don't understand oh
because I get I was watching an old clip
of mine from eight years ago cuz I
thought I was good I was like I'm good
and everyone be like no no no
so and somebody who like literally said
comedian X is better than you and I was
like okay so I sent him a clip from my
Comedy Central half-hour I did get on
Comedy Central barely a half hour of a
joke from eight years ago and it was a
[ __ ] good joke and I was like so why
did you tell me that someone so it was
better than me
and he was like I don't know I just had
a bias I said about and it's like people
don't want it something about me people
think I'm racist people think I'm
arrogant people think I'm cold I don't
know but it's not I'm I just don't get
the benefit at it up damn yeah but I
guess who wants to benefit of the doubt
right Nick yeah yes Dan your hope we
don't serve it here and now don't put me
on here because I don't want to feel
like I do yeah do not put me on I will
say we didn't pick those people it was
just that maneater
we didn't who did it just the guy this
guy Papio to New Zealand oh gotta go
people he listened junior touched this
one day and Gianni was like we should
put it on the wall
how did you out of the blue and sent you
the thing okay God Nick doesn't Nick
hates it he looks like himself I look
all sad I'm a pretty chipper guy I think
they got you they really have you but
it's so funny man the feeling of like
yeah I'm not included you're like I'm
not at the wall at the improv and we
didn't have it but yeah right yeah and
I'm just waiting to do it
what why not I know why not all right
isn't he does not know that that we
didn't even really have anything to do I
know and then I make this narrative up
yeah about how all you guys think and I
mean while you don't it has him across
your mind you haven't and but but that's
what the human [ __ ] brain does yeah
we just want to be included man yeah
Neal Brennan thank you so much man
[Music]
[Music]
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself on my
[Music]
[Music]